pierre laurent le numéro un du parti
communiste français est l'invité de
preuves par 3 avec l' agence
france-presse dailymotion bonsoir soit
avec nous avec donc ce soir kate et le
prix jean de la fp et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat nous allons
bien sûr abordé les grandes questions
politiques et économiques à cinq jours
du premier tour des élections
municipales où vous fait alliance dans
la majorité des cas avec le ps alors ça
peut surprendre puisque ce sont des
listes gouvernementales comme le dit
votre autres partenaires le parti de
gauche de jean luc mélenchon mais
d'abord pierre laurent le retour d'un
très agréable parfum de guerre froide
après l'annexion de la crimée par
vladimir poutine manifestement
totalement insensible aux pressions
occidentales est ce que vous partagez la
même indignation qui courent de paris à
washington en passant par toutes les
capitales européennes je pense que
l'annexion par par poutine est
extrêmement inquiétante elle le
référendum s'est fait dans des
conditions
préoccupante parce que sous enfin avec
des hommes armés un peu partout un
référendum qui me proposait en vérité
qu'une solution
donc cet inquiétant bon ceci étant dit
il y as en face aussi des
responsabilités des responsabilités
américaine des responsabilités l'union
européenne des responsabilité de l'otan
parce que nous avons accompagné une
situation en ukraine
inquiétante on a un pouvoir en ukraine
qui est qui au départ était une révolte
contre la corruption et puis qui est
devenu aujourd'hui un gouvernement dans
lequel il ya des ultranationalistes qui
pousse à l'inter a priori terre mais qui
sont quand même pour certains même il
faut le dire des antisémistes et des
fascistes qui pousse à la confrontation
eux aussi et malheureusement on est
moins en ce moment dans une escalade
militaire inquiétante plutôt d'ailleurs
que d'en rajouter d'un côté et de
l'autre sur la confrontation il faudrait
peut-être avancer des propositions qui
brille cet engrenage avec par exemple
les responsables les responsabilités
sont partagées dans la situation à
rennes louis dans l' escalade les
responsabilités sont partagées et par
exemple quand on a dit à un moment donné
dans la situation en ukraine que l'otan
allait jouer roll pour accompagner ce
qui se passait en ukraine eh bien on a
on a mis de l'huile sur le feu alors
qu'on sait qu'on est à la frontière dans
une frontière extrêmement tendu donc par
exemple il faudrait avancer des
propositions de démilitarisation de
l'ensemble de l'ukraine il faudrait
avancer des propositions pour que on
retourne à un processus démocratique en
ukraine par ce que l'on peut voir
actuelle le pouvoir actuel n'a pas été
élu il y a plus de pouvoir et lui en
ukraine actuellement donc il faudrait
que l'ensemble des ukrainiens puisse se
prononcer sur l'ensemble des questions
leur avenir économique
leurs rapports avec la russie et l'union
européenne
sur le régime qu'ils souhaitent etc on a
actuellement une situation d'instabilité
dans l'ukraine tout entière
des militaires même démilitarisé elle la
russie c'est elle qui fait pression
aujourd'hui avec son
armée
effectivement se poser d'une manière
beaucoup plus globale la question à la
démilitarisation des relations
internationales plutôt que d'aller vers
la confrontation est effectivement ne
pas remettre le doigt dans des logiques
de guerre froide des logiques de
confrontation qui ressemble d'ailleurs
plus qu'à des logiques de guerre froide
à des logiques de confrontation
impériale comme on en a connu avant la
première guerre mondiale est-ce qu'il
faut toujours invité patine le 6 juin
pour le 70e anniversaire du débarquement
écoutez je pense que les
l'anniversaire du débarquement
ne peut se faire qu'avec l'ensemble des
puissances donc vous voyez à l'époque
oui parce que de toute façon il faudra
du dialogue politique à tous les niveaux
et c'est pas aux pratiquants l'exclusion
des uns ou des autres qu'on va s'en
sortir est ce que le contrat des navires
militaires mistral un contrat qui avait
été signée par la france en 2011 avec
moscou et qui est important évidemment
pour l'emploi dans les chantiers navals
de saint nazaire doit être petit d'être
suspendu selon le mot de laurent fabius
qui met quand même beaucoup de
précautions oui je pense que là aussi on
est jeune je crains qu'on soit dans une
escalade qui ne traite pas le le le
problème véritable et qui ne contribue
pas à remettre au plus vite l'ensemble
des acteurs autour de la table donc des
puissances étrangères vivant et les
militaires en continu les premiers on
peut consulter non mais on peut discuter
avec ça vous savez sur les ventes
d'armes de la france y aurait beaucoup
de choses à dire sur les cas présent on
vend des armes à beaucoup de gens qui
les utilisent très mal dans le monde et
notamment beaucoup d'armes au qatar
qu'on retrouve disséminés dans tout le
sahel regard encore
beaucoup de choses à dire sur ça mais
dit mettons ces questions sur la table
dans une discussion avec la russie il
faut mettre toutes les questions sur la
table mais il faut aussi mettre les
questions est ce qu'on a besoin par
exemple d'élargir à la frontière de
l'otan à chaque fois aux portes de la
russie est ce qu'on peut pas avoir des
zones qui soit démilitarisé et qui est
vide mettre le doigt dans cet engrenage
militaire pour l'instant pas question de
suspendre ce contrat donc je pense que
ça n'est pas ce n'est pas mon ami la
première chose qu'il faut mettre à l'eau
alors vous avez défilé aujourd'hui avec
les syndicats et fo cgt notamment
contre le pacte de responsabilité
vous le dénoncez vous le présenter comme
une fuite en avant est ce que c'est le
bon timing franchement à cinq jours du
scrutin municipal écoutez on sait que le
gouvernement veut avancer très vite qui
veut dans la foulée des municipales
précipiter l'adoption du pacte de
responsabilité
il a mis même une pression énorme avec
l'aide du medef est en lien avec le
medef sur les syndicats pour arracher
des signatures sur un relevé de
conclusions qui ne comporte aucune
contrepartie en matière d'emploi donc le
c'est le gouvernement qui essayent de
presser le pas et d'éviter le débat sur
le pacte de responsabilité
donc je pense qu'il est important de
prendre l'initiative contre ça les
syndicats en ont pris et nous nous
allons reprendre et nous sommes en train
de construire un appel très large de
personnalités politiques syndicales
associatives à une marche contre
l'austérité le 12 avril appareils jean
pierre raffarin votre collègue sénat
pose une question qu'elle est peut-être
intéressant ces lignes avait combien de
chômeurs dans les cortèges ce mardi
contre le pacte de responsabilité
eh bien monsieur raffarin qui ne
fréquentent pas beaucoup les cortèges en
question il saurait s'il y allait
qu'effectivement on y côtoie des
salariés qui ont été au chômage et qui
des fois on retrouve un emploi et
inversement d d
des gens qui sont au chômage aujourd'hui
et qui n'arrive pas à retrouver vous
savez c'est pas en opposant ceux qui ont
un travail et ceux qui sont au chômage
qu'on va avancer vers la voie du progrès
social c'est un ajouté mme byrs la
droite opposée les salariés entre eux
mais quand on est chômeur au restant
salarié sont les chômeurs justement le
pacte de responsabilité prévoit un
allègement des charges notamment sur les
petits salaires et il ya une étude
récente qui dit que c'est efficace pour
créer de l'emploi dans le protestant wim
et je le conteste absolument parce que
les chiffres sont têtus on a on a cumulé
en vingt ans parce que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on fait ça
397 milliards d'euros d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales si on cumule toutes
les politiques d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales depuis 20 ans c'est
l'équivalent d'un budget entier de la
france et pour que le chômage record est
là mais la précarité galop pour reste
très taxés en france plus que j'aimerais
un européen avec nous mais vous savez
lire une menace mais bien rémunérer le
travail ce n'est pas un handicap pour
univers nous je parle pas du salaire je
parle des charges qui nous sommes et
c'est pas des charges les cotisations
sociales sassine ans la protection
sociale des salariés or effectivement
bien rémunérer le travail c'est à la
fois payer un bon salaire et s'est
assurée une protection sociale maladie
une protection contre le chômage une
protection enfin alors justement
politique d'allocation famille ou pour
financer pour financer les économies
nécessaires pour financer le pacte de
responsabilité est ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement a un plan caché pour
l'après municipal dont il va
malheureusement il n'a pas de plan caché
il a dit les choses il va payer
l'addition avec 50 milliards de
suppression dépense publique c'est à
dire de l'argent qui va être pris contre
les services publics et contre l'emploi
public donc on va dégrader les services
publics d'un côté et de l'autre côté on
va donner 2 à nouveau de l'argent aux
entreprises qui vont l'utiliser pour
accroître leur rentabilité et pour
verser des dividendes je rappelle quand
même parce qu'on parle là d'un plan qui
va alléger de 35 milliards que les
entreprises ont versé en 2013 des
entreprises du cac 40 ont versé en 2013
39 milliards d'euros de dividendes
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas le seul je
vois que benoît hamon que beaucoup
d'autres dans la majorité commencent à
pointer ce problème que moelle sur
lequel j'ai l'air depuis des mois ce que
j'appelle le coût du capital plutôt que
de regarder toujours du côté du coût du
travail on ferait bien de regarder du
côté du coup du qatar aux répondants
quelque sorte à vous directement il dit
j'ai le poil qui se hérisse quand
j'entends parler de cadeau au patronat
ceux qui disent ça ne connaissent rien à
l'entreprise d'accord bon ben il peut
être que son poil se hérisse mais la
vérité est elle et elle est têtue les
dividendes ont cru tout ces dernières
années et encore en 2013 pendant que
dans cette période de crise et bien il y
avait de plus en plus de chômeurs et de
gens qui souffraient de la situation et
monsieur gars tu as peut dire tout ce
qu'il veut les chiffres sont là aussi la
part des dividendes dans la valeur
ajoutée est maintenant supérieur à la
part de l'investissement donc nous avons
des entreprises qui préfèrent faire de
la croissance financière plutôt que
d'investir dans l'emploi feng hâtât
c'est vrai a salué le premier ministre
comme le dit thierry le paon de la cgt
en tout cas il est très très écouté
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
d'ailleurs il est le seul quasiment
applaudir et peut-être que il faudrait
ramener des syndicats vous l'avez
d'autres enseignés quand même un 1er mai
même ceux-là
même cela cette année de la dre des
extrémistes même cela il naples au 10
pas vivons ici quand même y signe il s'y
met
avec son remarqué que peut-être ils ne
sont pas sûrs du résultat ce qui est
très étonnant de signer mais ça c'est
leur responsabilité
j'ai pas mêler de ça mais non le sol qui
applaudit vraiment c'est pierre gattaz
depuis le début et d'ailleurs je crois
que les français le comprennent assez
bien il suffit de regarder ce que
pensent les gens de gauche de la
politique actuelle de françois hollande
on parle beaucoup d'un remaniement en ce
moment peut-être après aussi les
municipales comme le pacte de
responsabilité est ce que pour vous ça
peut avoir un sens si c'est un
remaniement pour faire comme on
'l'annonce un gouvernement resserré voir
comme l'a dit monsieur gattaz il nous
faut un gouvernement de combat un
gouvernement de combat pour accélérer
dans cette direction évidemment que ça
ne peut pas me satisfaire
il faut totalement changé de cap et prob
il faudrait changer l'équipe
gouvernementale mais pas dans le sens
pour faire une politique zéro pour
regarder faire la place à matignon pour
faire un pôle it mais ce n'est pas une
question d'homme c'est pour faire une
politique de gauche qu'on ne fait pas
actuellement est-ce que où il ya quand
même des ministres qui tirent mieux leur
épingle du jeu vous avez cité benoît
hamon qui vient un peu sur vos positions
concernant
ben ali dans le magazine l'usiné
nouvelle déclare sa flamme cette semaine
pour arnaud montebourg et on peut le
dire c'est le meilleur défenseur des
usines que la france ait connu depuis 30
ans êtes vous d'accord écoutez j'ai été
il ya quelques jours à dunkerque j'ai
rencontré tous les salariés de la
sidérurgie les salariés d'ascométal
qui dont l'entreprise vient d'être mais
mise en redressement les salariés
d'arcelor dunkerque j'étais l'autre jour
à côté de la halle jean à fumel avec sa
salariée de métal tant que j'ai
rencontré samedi les salariés de fralib
tous me disent arnaud montebourg nous
fait beaucoup de promesses mais nous on
ne voit pas les résultats et pour cause
parce que arnaud montebourg est
pleinement aux communications mais ça ne
change pas une politique gouvernementale
qui ne permet pas de s'attaquer à la
politique du chômage un mot sur le
climat quelques jours des municipales
pierre laurent préjudiciable semble-t-il
à la droite comme à la gauche et un
sondage montrent d'ailleurs que presque
la majorité bonne moitié des français 60
un dégoût je relis je crois que les
français ils disent une chose très
simple de mon sens que je partage à
1000% occupez vous des problèmes de la
france et des français quand il voit
pendant une semaine les responsables
politiques du gouvernement et de la
droite se jeter à la figure des affaires
à milieu de leurs préoccupations
effectivement ils sont en colère parce
que eux ils souffrent ils attendent un
gouvernement et ils attendent des
responsables politiques qu'ils soient
mobilisés sur les problèmes essentiels
de la france mais là je sens là des
responsables politiques se jettent les
injustices enquête la justice enquête et
elle a besoin d'encaisser ce tome en
jean luc marchand affirme que françois
hollande était forcément au courant des
écoutes judiciaires de nicolas sarkozy
vous avez le même la même conviction
probablement il a été un moment donné
mais ce qui emporte dans cette affaire
c'est deux choses dans ces affaires
c'est que la justice travaille parce que
manifestement il ya des choses à
éclaircir du côté de nicolas sarkozy
et deuxièmement que le gouvernement
actuel ne se mêlent pas d'intervenir
dans l'ain dans l'instruction judiciaire
et laisse les juges travaillent et voilà
il faut faire les donc dans les deux cas
la réponse aller simple il faut que la
justice travaille et que les
responsables politiques eux se mêle de
enfin s'occuper des problèmes des
français n'est pas autre chose qu'un tel
président de la lfp va nous rejoindre
dans un instant d'abord on va parler de
vous et de jean luc mélenchon puisque
vous formez quand même un drôle de
couple qui s'est retrouvé il ya quelques
jours enfin pourrait-on dire on va le
voir à nîmes le reportage de faustine
saint geniès
l'image est rare et sans trucage pierre
laurent et jean-luc mélenchon ensemble
mais cela ressemble à de fausses
retrouvailles pour la première et la
dernière fois de la campagne des
municipales
vendredi dernier à nîmes les deux hommes
ont fait estrade commune mais le courant
ne passe pas vraiment
ce qui rassemble ici à nîmes c'est cette
liste de gauche qui fait rêver jean luc
mélenchon ou parti communiste parti de
gauche écologistes et même quelques
socialistes font front commun
soir à nîmes par nous voulons faire la
démonstration que c'est toi laissions du
front de gauche et d'europe écologie les
verts avec les socialistes critiquent le
retourne à mes juges sur lequel sont
embarqués j'ai les doigts les yeux aux
invocations à les premières
pierre laurent lui est dans une toute
autre stratégie il veut maintenir le
parti communiste face notamment à la
menace du front national
ont brusqué
principal point de crispation entre les
deux hommes les rapports avec le ps
alors que les communistes ont fait des
alliances dans de nombreuses villes
comme paris jean luc mélenchon prône une
autonomie radical vis-à-vis des
socialistes est pour lui l'occasion ce
sera les européennes après les
municipales on va démarrer puis c'est
mon intérêt qu'on est pas après les
municipales quand même
au moins qu'on puisse dire bah on tourne
la page on passe à autre chose passer à
autre chose faute de quoi le front de
gauche est menacée d'implosion
voilà après ces images qui vous rappelle
quelques souvenirs récents
nous inquiète très beau meeting à nîmes
où il y avait 1000 personnes entre vos
deux avec mélenchon savagnières un petit
peu le froid quand même qu'à tel prison
peut témoigner elle était sur place
devant soi quelles seraient vos
questions à notre avis michel le disait
drôle de couple effectivement les
retrouvailles étaient un petit peu
froide tendu à nîmes vendredi soir vous
en êtes où avec jean luc mélenchon
finale non elle n'était pas spécialement
tendu on est et on a maintenant on a
retrouvé un rythme régulier de
discussion on se voit et on se parle
quasiment tous les jours en ce moment
sur la situation et sur la suite des
élections municipales et la préparation
des élections européennes pourtant lui a
l'air de dire que la blessure n'est pas
refermée queue il attend effectivement
la fin des municipales comment qu'on
vous à les surmonter
ce qu'est ce qui a aussi un problème de
fond je crois que ce qui ce qui aidera à
tourner la page chez les résultats des
élections municipales finalement tout le
monde fera un peu le bilan de ce qui a
été fait par les uns et par les autres
nous nous avons fait des choix que nous
revendiquons jusqu'à ce jour parce que
ils vont permettre de conforter le parti
communiste le front de gauche comme le
troisième réseau d'élus locaux de toutes
les formations politiques nationales et
je pense que c est lui seront utiles
pour mener les batailles contre
l'austérité et la suite donc
je ne crois pas que les élections
municipales vont invalider les choix qui
ont été les nôtres au contraire
chacun partant de la gauche parce que
j'espérais mais non non je n'espère pas
du tout ça j'ai pas d'ennemis surtout
pas au front gauche et j'en ai pas
d'ailleurs j'en ai pas à gauche prg
ainsi mes ennemis sont d'abord à droite
et à l'extrême droite enfin les
adversaires politiques disons
donc chacun tirera les leçons les tirs a
collectivement et on va avancer avancer
vers la suite on a eu effectivement des
accords qui d'un désaccord important
c'est que nous nous considérons que le
fait d'avoir de très nombreux élus c'est
important pour défendre des populations
et monnaie de bataille qu'on prend du
talent vous associer au ps on l'agent
nommé en janvier le front de gauche
devient invisible on est en train de
s'associer à un parti qu'on critique
qu'il critique à longueur d'année je
pense que la peau la protection des
politiques publiques locales qui vont
mettre être être mis en cause par les
injonctions d'austérité qui vont venir
du medef du gouvernement de bruxelles de
la cour des comptes je pense que la
protection de ces politiques publiques
locales pour le logement les transports
publics méritent qu'on qu'on se batte
pour constituer des majorités
municipales de gauche qu'on laisse pas
les villes retourner à droite et pire à
l'extrême droite est évidemment c'est
majorité municipale de gauche
continueront d'être traversés par des
débats mais je pense que nous serons en
meilleure position pour protéger ses
politiques publiques et moi j'accorde de
l'importance à ça et quand on le dit on
peut se passer de toute alliance avec
d'autres forces de gauche je dis ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas la réalité
politique d'ailleurs nous faisons
alliance et jean luc mélenchon s'en
félicite avec les verts à nîmes et dans
d'autres villes que je sache est aussi
une formation qui pour le moment a
choisi de rester au gouvernement donc
nous travaillons avec des forces on voit
bien dans le parti socialiste des gens
qui sont qui sont en débat aussi sur
l'orientation gouvernementale et
heureusement que nous dalloway il y en a
il y en a d'ailleurs aussi sur la liste
à nîmes dont tous les deux que tous les
deux nous avons été soutenir est ce que
vous comprenez toujours ce que dit jean
luc mélenchon peut-être qu'on va vous
expliquer parce qu'il est par exemple
elle a lancé récemment contre un meeting
ce n'est pas à nîmes c'était à paris
dimanche au jeu ne m'appartient plus
non mais écoutez nous en parler avec lui
au téléphone non mais ça c'était quoi
moi je pense que il faut toujours quand
on s'investit en politique et
singulièrement quand on est investi des
premières responsabilités qu'on ait mis
sur le devant comme on l'a été c'est il
faut garder du recul en tout cas c'est
un point c'est important donc voilà
que moi je ne pourra pas mais chacun sa
personnalité pour venir aux mines et aux
municipales justement et ses problèmes
d'éthique est jean luc mélenchon accuse
manuel vaches de vouloir faire une
grande ratatouille des étiquettes et de
noyer le front de gauche ou le parti de
gauche on hésite quel est ce que
pensaient la même chose oui je peux vous
avez les élections aux municipales il ya
des il ya des coalitions différents
d'une ville à l'autre donc c'est très
difficile de faire des additions
nationale par formation politique donc
on a vu parfois et souvent des
ministères des ministres de l'intérieur
tenté par des additions improbable donc
ivre il faudra se méfier de ça dimanche
soir pour lire attentivement les
résultats il suffira pas de lire les
additions par formation politique il
faudra regarder les coalitions qui l'ont
emporté leur nature donc faut une
lecture un peu plus fine que ça et
effectivement il faudra peut-être se
méfier un peu de ce qu'on nous dira le
dimanche soir du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur il faudra y regarder de près
en tout cas je pense qu'il faudra aider
les électeurs et à y regarder de près
vous y regarder de près vous vous conter
par rapport à jean luc mélenchon est
derrière vous dites vous mettez en route
pour les européennes est ce que les
discussions avancent et aussi avec vos
partenaires je le souhaite depuis des
mois on a pris on a pris du retard bon
là maintenant on est dans la dernière
ligne droite des élections européennes
donc nous avons commencé des discussions
il ya déjà eu deux réunions du front de
gauche ces derniers jours il y en a une
troisième demain matin je pense que nous
maintenons notre objectif il est clair
c'est net prêt dès le lendemain des
élections des élections municipales je
pense que nous devrions y arriver enfin
je vois pas ce qui pourrait s'y opposer
nous sommes sur la question européenne
en face depuis très longtemps nous
soutenons une candidature commune à
l'échelle de toute l'europe qui est
celle du leader de la gauche grecque
alexis tsipras ce nous avons beaucoup de
bien commun sur la question européenne
je ne vois pas pourquoi nous y nous
n'irions pas ensemble aux élections
européennes je le pense depuis déjà des
mois quels que soient les résultats
quels que soient les objectifs au second
tour d'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez vous au second tour des
municipales
moi je pense que il va falloir vraiment
se rassembler contre la droite et
l'extrême droite la priorité des
priorités pour le second tour sera le
rassemblement face à la droite et à
l'extrême droite dans toutes les
circonstances et il faudra pour le faire
que chacun en fasse les efforts de
rassemblement qui respectent les
résultats du premier tour qui respecte
les différentes forces mais il faudra
travailler d'arrache-pied à ce
rassemblement parce que très
probablement nous risquons de nous
trouver face à des situations de menaces
de basculement de ville vers la droite
et l'extrême droite et quelles que
soient les débats qui a dans la gauche
qui sont très vifs en ce moment surtout
avec un gouvernement je pense que ça
devrait être une priorité pour le
deuxième 3 pour en revenir aux
européennes les discussions visite
avance la place de jean luc mélenchon
est déjà définie on des petites fuites
dans la presse qui disent qu'ils
seraient dans le sud ouest que ça se
bataille quand même encore pour l'île de
france ce que tout ça est encore en
cours vraiment vous attend dès le
lendemain des municipales non il ya des
il ya effectivement des discussions nous
pour ce qui est du parti communiste aux
nous nous avons sont deux principes
simples c'est à dire que là il le plus
simple serait de reconduire les sortants
dont dans les circonscriptions ils ont
été élus donc jean luc mélenchon dans le
sud ouest patrick le hyaric député
communiste européen en ile de france une
députée européenne non-encartés qui est
dans le front gauche
marie christine vergiat dans le sud est
donc et jacky hénin dans le nord voilà
voilà notre proposition et à partir de
là et bien ce procédé à une répartition
est au pouvoir à une ouverture des
listes dans les autres circonscriptions
ça discute un peu sur ça mais je pense
qu'on va y arriver jean luc mélenchon a
toujours affirmé que son objectif était
que ces listes volistes arrive devant
celles du parti socialiste n'est ce pas
qu'a t'elle pas ce que vous partagez cet
objectif je pense qu aux élections
européennes les électeurs de gauche qui
voudront mettre un bulletin anti
austérité dans l'urne clairement anti
austérité et pour une europe solidaire
pas sur une position de repli et pour
une europe des travailleurs solidaires
et bien au 1 8 1 pour le faire un
bulletin efficace la liste du fric oui
donc je pense qu'on peut aller très haut
et dans certaines circonscriptions en
tout cas peut-être être en tête de la
gauche oui absolument je pense que c'est
aux élections européennes nous nous
avons nous le savons que nous sommes
déjà beaucoup plus haut que ce que nous
avions fait en 2009 les sondages le
disent et on n'est pas entré en campagne
je pense qu'on peut faire un très bon
score si on se met aux campagnes rapine
ce que vous êtes prêts à ouvrir vos
listes au npa je pense que on pourrait
ouvrir nos listes et de tous côtés moi
j'essaye de discuter aussi avec des des
socialistes qui se pose beaucoup de
questions sur la politique la politique
actuelle qui sont pas d'accord avec le
pack de responsabilité qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'interrogations qui
s'inquiètent de cette orientation mais
effectivement ça peut ça peut aussi des
discussions avec l'anpaa le l'idéal ça
serait que ça s'ouvre de tous côtés dans
toutes les familles de à gauche pour
faire les listes les plus larges
possibles il ya quelques changements
j'ai envie de vous demander ce que vous
saluer depuis le passage du sarkozysme
hollandisme
écoutez je ne sais pas ce que c'est le
hall on dise mauvaise politique de
françois et leur change je sais pas si
c'est lui et et avait envie de saluer
depuis l'alternance il y a eu il ya eu
le mariage pour tous il ya eu il ya eu
cette avancée et bien c'est vrai qu'au
plan économique et social c'est la
déception sur toute la ligne et même
pire que ça parce qu'on a donc dans
plusieurs domaines l'accord national de
l'ani qui a été la loi qui est un recul
des droits sociaux on a eu un recul du
droit à la retraite on s'oriente avec le
pack de responsabilité vers des choses
inquiétantes donc on a malheureusement
en matière économique et sociale plutôt
de la continuité du changement et puis
il ya eu cette avancée sociétale il ya
eu dans le domaine de l'éducation soit
soixante mille pose de créer c'était un
rattrapage par rapport à la période
sarkozy mais on est très loin des
besoins et maintenant on nous dit à
cause des 50 milliards d'économies qu'on
veut faire c'est que même ces postes-là
alors que c'était soi-disant la grande
priorité ne serait plus sans que tu as
he is et donc on a des inquiétudes
grandissent donc c'est une pincée
hollandisme quand que pensez vous de la
position des écologistes avec lesquels
vous êtes associé dans certaines villes
pour les municipales et qui participe au
gouvernement ce que je comprends de lors
de leur débat et puis je discute avec
eux c'est qu'ils sont ils ont ils sont
très inquiets de lorient de beaucoup de
choses dans l'orientation
gouvernementale ils ne sont pas
satisfaits de ce qu'ils n'avancent pas
en matière écologique et je crois qu'ils
ont ils ont raison le débat sur la
pollution la montre et encore on
n'avance pas assez vite
ils sont aussi à dans l'or dans leurs
rangs beaucoup de gens inquiets par les
orientations sociales du gouvernement
ils essayent de peser de l'intérieur sur
les orientations gouvernementales
c'est un choix qui leur appartient qui
fait débat chez eux moi j'ai pas mêler
de ce choix ils essayent à leur manière
de peser pour le moment il n'y arrive
pas beaucoup
et comment ils vont faire évoluer leurs
positions mais moi je constate que comme
j'arrive à le faire avec des socialistes
sur le terrain avec des écologistes nous
arrivions à constituer par exemple des
majorités municipales ou des accords
municipaux avec des objectifs qui sont
des vrais objectifs de gauche donc ça
veut dire que le combat doit continuer
et qu'une majorité alternative qui
rassemblerait à terme des gens venus de
toutes les familles de la gauche pour
mener autre chose que les politiques
d'austérité actuelle est nécessaire et
qu'elle est possible et ça reste notre
objectif donc une sortie d écologie du
gouvernement vous leur tendait la main
pour rejoindre le front de gauche mais
je leur tends la main même en étant au
gouvernement et je tends la main à des
socialistes qui ont et qui s ou qui sont
dans une formation qui sont un
gouvernement parce que nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà travaillé ensemble nous
proposons une grande marche contre
l'austérité le 12 avril contre le pacte
de responsabilité pour un contre la
droite et l'extrême droite et nous
disons à des verts à des socialistes
venez avec nous dans cette manière six
mois tout le monde voilà que françois
hollande est sans gouvernement reste au
sol mais il s'est isolé il s'est isolé
tout seul françois hollande qui le
soutient il a il est à 20% popularité
deux ans après avoir été élu président
de la république il a il a tourné le dos
aux gens de gauche les gens de gauche ne
lui font plus confiance et effectivement
il s'est isolé et c'est à nous de
rassembler maintenant ses forces qui ne
se reconnaissent pas dans la politique
gouvernementale pour reconstituer une
autre majorité que celle là qui mènera
une politique de bush
merci et katell allez on va s'intéresser
maintenant au combat électoral
particulier qui se déroule en ce moment
en seine-saint-denis un département où
le communisme municipal comme on dit un
père laurent a encore quelques lettres
de noblesse mais va-t-on bientôt dire
avait puisque claude bartelone l'homme
fort du département qui est également le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
décidé manifestement de ne pas vous
faire de cadeaux on en parle avec
perrine tarneaud dans un instant après
ce reportage sur place de ce financement
nous madame
vous allez vous allez bien
je laisse mon petit frère il fait partie
de ces jeunes loups socialiste surnommés
les barthes aux boys mathieu hanotin 35
ans jeune député et vice président du
conseil général connaît bien le
département de seine saint denis
aujourd'hui il est à la conquête de ce
bastion communiste kke et la ville de
saint denis
poussé par le président de l'assemblée
nationale claude bartolone oui j'ai des
affinités politiques particulières avec
le bartolone oui on partage le même
projet politique pour la
seine-saint-denis oui on a travaillé
ensemble au conseil général oui on
travaille ensemble à l'assemblée
nationale oui je suis fier notre pôle
marketing chez chaque jour pour
promouvoir partout il le peut le
département la seine saint denis face à
lui soutenu par marie george buffet
didier paillard maire communiste sortant
il regrette qu aucune alliance n'était
possible avec les socialistes y voit là
la patte de claude bartolone se sert de
ses jeunes militants
je rejoins de députés pour pour aller à
la conquête de
golovin ça se manifeste par sa présence
régulière enfin havas lui-même il nous
honore tous les semaines de sa présence
d'une façon ou d'une autre dans bord des
événements qu'ont deux fois rien à voir
avec la vie politique claude bartolone
omniprésent mais qui fuit les médias son
idée poussé le parti communiste or de
seine-saint-denis alors que sur les 40
communes que compte le département seuls
11 sont encore sous le giron du pc une
offensive inédite dans ce département
historiquement communiste jugée
agressive pour leurs armes est rude et
du département il sait pas de la
concurrence c'est d'extermination c'est
le couteau du boucher socialiste qui
veut égorger les quelques communistes
qui reste dans ce département il se
présente presque partout contre c'est
vrai à saint denis c'est vrai à bagnolet
c'est vrai à aubervilliers c'est vrai à
saint-ouen c'est vrai même à villepinte
enfin donc presque toutes les communes
que détient le parti communiste le parti
socialiste se présente contre eux pour
les éliminer comme ils l'ont fait du
conseil général l'enjeu caché de ces
municipales en seine saint denis serait
le grand paris claude bartolone ne cache
pas son envie de diriger la future
métropole s'il ne joue qu'un rôle
secondaire dans ces municipales lui qui
n'est candidat qu'à un modeste poste de
conseiller municipal au pré saint
gervais le patron du département comme
on l'appelle place ses pions
voilà donc pour claude bartolone est ce
qu'on appelle maintenant les barthes boy
bonsoir perrine tarneaud questions sur
ce thème à notre invité bonsoir pierre
laurent est ce que vous reprenez le
terme de jean christophe lagarde
convient d'entendre dans ce reportage il
parle d'extermination des communistes
dans le département de la
seine-saint-denis l'extermination par le
parti socialiste et par claude bartolone
mais ils on parle en connaissance de
cause parce qu'il a pratiqué la même
chose dans la ville de drancy aux
alentours donc effet il ya d'ailleurs
des connivences des connivences
dangereuse on seine-saint-denis vous
avez pour éliminer les comédies par
exemple pour éliminer les communistes on
voit parcours parfois se construire des
coalitions extrêmement extrêmement
inquiétante récemment le le front
national qui n'a pas réussi à présenter
une liste à sony a déclaré qu'
il fallait éradiquer l'équipe paillard
le maire le maire communiste de saint
denis en disant peut un peu peu importe
si le ch et le le chirurgien est
socialiste et socialise donc
effectivement on voit des parfois des
coalition contre nature pour essayer
nous a fait bien mais je pense que la
situation ne s'y prête pas en ce moment
parce que les populations seine saint
denis ont besoin de solidarité elles ont
besoin de politique
protectrice et je pense que les
opérations qui sont menées actuellement
dans quelques villes
inspiré par claude bartolone je crois
qu'elles vont échouer cette fois ci en
seine-saint-denis mais quel est
l'objectif de claude bartolone
c'est d'avoir à une hégémonie
sur le département de la seine et au
delà et au de l'info il faut il faut
croire oui ils font croire que c'est une
c'est un objectif qui possède qui était
assez loin mais qui est assez loin
pourtant de l'intérêt des populations
non mais prônons la ville sony parle on
concrètement cette ville qui a été
touchée il ya plusieurs décennies par
une très grave d industrialisation
aujourd'hui c'est une ville en plein
développement c'est une ville qui a ré
industrialiser tout plaine commune c'est
une ville qui autour stade de france
fait du développement c'est une période
70 emplacements à ben c'est parce que il
connaît pas bien la ville de saint denis
si elle fait confiance justement aux
équipes qui écroulent qui ont conduit la
ville c'est parce que il y à danser dans
ces villes des politiques de solidarité
qui les protège des politiques dans les
cantines scolaires des politiques de
développement de l'emploi des politiques
de service public culturel et des
députés socialistes sur les marchés elle
a aidé à il le dit aux électeurs qui
rencontra est acquis et distribue non
seulement des écharpe rose mais ces
tracts évidemment maintenant faut
tourner la page assez durs et les
communistes oui mais ça ça c'est une
rhétorique qui ne ressemble pas beaucoup
un homme de gauche voilà c'est une
rhétorique on entend beaucoup chez chez
des hommes de droite qui vole qui
veulent se débarrasser des fois des
communistes et des fois des socialistes
et or dans ces villes là ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est du rassemblement de
toutes les forces de gauche ne voulons
pas une hégémonie communiste en seine
saint denis qui n'existe d'ailleurs voir
passer nous voulons nous voulons que les
forces qui sont à gauche dans ce
département s'unissent pour protéger les
populations contre les politiques de
spéculation et politiques de chômage qui
m'a frappé dans les candidats
socialistes de ce département mais aussi
haut dans la petite couronne parisienne
c'est finalement le non-cumul la
limitation du cumul et bien ça attendra
2010 est monsieur en attaque on a vu
dans le reportage est déjà député et
vice président du conseil général il se
présente comme tête de liste il ya bruno
le roux aussi dans le département qui se
présentent en troisième place par en
tête de liste no le parti socialiste
finalement fait voter une loi sur la
limitation du monde parce que b et qui
nourrit quand on est plus
préoccupés par l'intérêt général mais
seulement par les ambitions personnelles
des uns des autres et de jeunes députés
qui parce qu'ils ont été élus à la
faveur d'une vague rose en législatif
pensent que tout leur est permis on voit
on voit ce que ça donne et d'ailleurs on
a le même cas en seine saint denis
lejeune député socialiste élu razzy
hammadi s'est lancé marcelo c'est long
c'est pareil n'importe comment dans la
bataille à montreuil va finir et il va
finir très vite à claude bartolone lacie
nous écoute tu ne feras pas la peau et
c'est ça ça me paraît clair je pense que
en seine saint denis il ya une volonté
je pense qu'il ya une crise je lui dis
clairement
il ya une volonté des populations de
redévelopper de redévelopper
l'influencent du parti communiste du
front de gauche et de la gauche toute
entière parce que nous nous servons la
gauche on va parler un petit peu la
pollution en ile-de-france avec
l'application la cime de la circulation
alternée hier à paris est-ce que selon
vous c'est une décision politique et
électoraliste avant tout
non c'est une décision il ya un vrai
problème il ya un vrai problème de
pollution sur l'innocence il ne doit pas
ce oui ce week-end donc effectivement là
c'est un coup une fois on nous dit ça a
été utile moi j'ai pas le moyen de le
vérifier que ça à faire descendre
immédiatement la pollution mais on sait
qu on traitera pas le problème dans la
durée avec des coups difficiles
d'anticipation il ya un déficit depuis
très longtemps on a on a pris 20 ans de
retard en développement des services pu
les transports publics en ile de france
on a laissé depuis 20 ans développe le
fret sur la route là l'île de france
comme malheureusement toutes les régions
de france est envahie de camions et
qu'on ne développe pas le fret
ferroviaire il ya des grandes gares de
fret ferroviaire en ile de france à
villeneuve saint georges à blanc mesnil
qui ne sont pas développées comme elle
le devrait
je vous raconte une chose je suis allé
visiter rungis il ya quelques jours et
bien il y a des lignes de fret qui
viennent du sud de la france pour amener
les fruits et légumes c'est bien non si
elles servent mais la sncf vont fermer
une des deux si on supprime cette ligne
eh bien on aura des camions
supplémentaires que voilà que le
gouvernement s'occupe de ça elle a
d'abord été organisé le fret voilà voilà
une mesure concrète voilà on ile de
france et qui sera celle-là pérenne
durable défendre les lignes de chemin de
fer qui amènent des fruits et légumes à
régis tous les matins plutôt que de
transporter ses fruits les gars vous
allez gagner depuis perpignan compte
abonné mais on sait jamais à quel
horizon s être emparée de cinéma
l'odyssée
toi tandina les camions tandis que les
cadets c'est d'une grande fiabilité
résister la position des camions
pourquoi vous parlez pas de la pollution
du dièse et des voitures diesel aussi il
y à aussi il ya aussi un problème avec
mais ça pour régler ce problème là il
faut faire évoluer le parc automobile il
faut mais ça pareil c'est un plan de
transition durable il faut il faut
travailler avec les constructeurs
automobiles faire évoluer le parc
automobile et puis encouragé les les
automobilistes à acheter dès qu'il faut
de plus taxer à l'est
oui mais justement c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut prendre le problème parce que
là on culpabilise toujours les mêmes
c'est comme hier on a
mis la main à des gens qui essayaient
d'aller travailler avec l'envoi n'en
ayant pas peut-être services mhcs
certains pouvaient peut-être faire
autrement je sais pas mais mon soit dit
entre nous petite anecdote sur la
journée d'hier il y avait beaucoup de
contrôles à la porte de montreuil à la
porte de bagnolet on pouvait pas passer
à travers ouais mais mais pas à porte de
saint-cloud un porte d'auteuil avant
que je dis de discrimination sociale
dans les contrôles hier la lumière il
n'y avait pas de contrôle à la porte
d'auteuil à la porte de saint-cloud par
contre vous pouviez pas rentrer dans
paris avec une voiture à la porte de
bagnolet mais bon sa mise à part je sais
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs je pose une
question jamais la question parce que je
n'ai pas de pression j'ai pas
l'impression que les voitures
polluent moins à l'ouest de paris
calèches à paris elle veut éradiquer le
diesel est ce qu'elle en a les moyens
mais effet mais il faut encourager les
gens on les a encouragés à acheter des
voitures diesel et maintenant on va les
matraques et c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
je le problème donc faisons évoluer le
parc par exemple on peut le faire très
vite évoluer dans tout le parc des
autobus des voilà tout ce qui est
maîtrisée par la puissance publique est
tous les parcs publics peuvent évoluer
on vient de bus en ile-de-france entre
amis le gall anne hidalgo et cécile
duflot c'était ce week-end sur la
pollution est ce que votre avis en
hidalgo en ce moment elle fait preuve
d'un peu de fébrilité là en cette fin de
campagne elle a peur de l'abstention
importante à gauche qui pourrait la
pénaliser
lité non c'est pas le sait pas
l'impression j'ai participé à un meeting
avec elle dans le 20e arrondissement qui
est mon arrondissement j'ai pas senti
une candidate fébrile il ya une campagne
qui semaine à paris qui est de mon point
de vue une bonne campagne qui avance des
propositions précises nous avons beau
nous allons jouer un rôle extrêmement
utile pour que les propositions soient
précises notamment sur la question du
logement social des transports publics
des halles alimentaire donc je pense que
mes mais le problème de la mobilisation
électorale
se pose à paris comme ailleurs à cause
d'un climat national qui effectivement
qui effectivement pas très pas très bon
et par une analyse at her and i vergote
être réticentes à l'éventuelle fusion de
ces listes de vos listes avec celles du
parti gauche elle dit ça ne serait pas
cohérent ou à écouter moi je pense que
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure au 2e tour
il faudra donner la priorité au
rassemblement contre la droite et
l'extrême droite c'est donc pour moi ça
ça veut dire le rassemblement maximum un
nouveau 2e tour du tout ce qui se dit
non non non attendez je dis il faut la
logique d'ensemble doit être le
rassemblement maximum pour faire face à
la droite et à l'extrême droite et moi
c'est ce que je souhaite voilà c'est
magique du second tour en effaçant new
beat ou non mais pourrait venir des
tours dans des configurations qui sont
différents et puis au deuxième tour on
se rassemble pour battre la droite et
l'extrême - et je pense que ça continue
de fonctionner et d'être efficace allez
tiens encore une occasion de dire du mal
de la politique suivie et de françois
hollande va regretter que les étrangers
ne participent pas au scrutin municipal
mais bien sûr c'est écouter ça fait
depuis 80 ans les présidents socialistes
ont fait cette promesse et l'orangé une
fois élu c'est pour moi c'est indigne
déjà lourd celle que vous avez salué sur
les mariages canto résident gauche c'est
pas très très ambitieux quand même on
est lorsque si une réforme sociétale ça
commence à faire peur à la mouche alors
là on effectivement on est mal barré
voilà qui est dit c'était clair et net
depuis le début de cette émission merci
perrine merci pierre laurent je retrouve
dimanche soir à partir de 19 heures sur
la chaîne public sénat avec
lcp-assemblée nationale pour bien sûr la
soirée des municipales la semaine
prochaine lors de l'entré deux tours
perrine et bien il y aura deux preuves
par 3 mardi et mercredi a très vite